il y a quelqu'un autour de la table qui
a touché une fortune pour être offert en
cadeau en fait ne dit pas il y a
quelqu'un dites reprenez votre Benjamin
Castaldi donc allez-y alors je pense
qu'il n'aime pas que je raconte cette
anecdote mais je vais vous la raconter
alors j'espère juste que des personnes
des impôts nous regardent
je vais commencer puis il va finir parce
que sinon je vais tout raconter donc ça
se passe au château de Chambord d'accord
Benjamin Castaldi avait été booké par un
homme marié pour être allez je m'en vais
allez allez faut être pour faire je dis
tout pour être offert en cadeau à sa
femme
et donc les enchères étaient montés
Benjamin Muscat
100000 € 120 euros
d'abord
la vérité alors c'était il y a 13 ans ça
remonte à plus de plus de 2 semaines
début des années 2000 et par là voilà et
en fait j'étais offert en cadeau j'étais
à Chambord une soirée un peu Alouette
shot avec les gens un peu avec des trucs
pas tellement habillés en fait et je
suis arrivé en hélicoptère quoi il y
avait la dame qui était sur le perron
et c'était une soirée absolument
incroyable
alors c'est qui ta meuf à l'époque alors
je ne sais plus
je ne sais plus du tout
proposé 20000 le gars proposés
non 100000 je viens 100000 100000 €
comme ça
en fait j'étais offert en cadeau après
j'étais voilà j'étais gentleman j'ai
voilà ça va pas
c'était juste j'étais juste là
de grandes oreilles c'est pour écouter
ce qui se passe dans les couloirs de
TPMP même à 100 mètres de distance non
mais c'est vrai il arrive à tout
entendre tout voir tout sentir bravo
Gilles en tout cas et tout me rapporter
merci bien sûr c'est bien pour ça que tu
es le meilleur élève de la classe donc
moi Castaldi on lui avait proposé une
soirée pour laquelle nous a proposé
100000 euros pour venir donc en cadeau
pour pour la maîtresse la maîtresse de
maison
c'est très Chambord très très belle
soirée en hélicoptère la dame
m'attendait sur le perron sur le perron
et elle est habillée mais assez
légèrement je dois dire
que toi qui rencontre des oufs comme ça
et en fait j'ai compris qu'en fait je
voilà je devais être gentil avec la dame
donc
comme je suis bien élevé et poli
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]